toutes les grandes banques du canada en
plus de desjardins se joindre au
boycottage de facebook
elle s'engage à ne plus acheter de
publicité sur facebook et instagram qui
appartient facebook pour un mois
les institutions financières suivent
l'exemple de centaines d'entreprises qui
participent au mouvement non à la haine
pour les profits cette mobilisation
s'inscrit contre les publications
polarisantes antisémite anti noirs sur
facebook le réseau social a récemment
supprimé 250 groupes suprémaciste blanc
avec new delhi brière stratège
formatrice conférencière en
communication numérique et réseaux
sociaux bon soir dans ça est-ce que ce
boycottage un réel impact économique
pour facebook passé assez relatif là on
va se dire c'est seulement pour un mois
premièrement il faut comprendre que le
marché de facebook des annonceurs
publicitaires baissent et surtout des
petits annonceurs des petites
entreprises moyens dans l'entreprise et
à près de nantes 7 et 8 million
d'annonceurs et il ya même un comptage
qui a été fait par la société
mathématique qui établit qu signe par
exemple 100 des compagnies les plus
dépensières sur la plateforme participer
à ce boycott
alors c'est pas le cas pour toutes
celles ci la ben on peut créer même pas
si c'est pour ça le des revenus et que
la plupart des entreprises qui achètent
de la publicité sur facebook n'ont pas
les moyens de ne pas le faire parce que
souvent ils ont quelques centaines de
dollars a placé par ci par là ils ont
pas les moyens de faire affaire avec des
agences pour avoir du graphisme et tout
ça alors que sur la plateforme c du clé
en main et vous pouvez émettre n'importe
quel montant à partir de là peu près une
vingtaine de dollars
donc l'impact financier est relatif
parce que c'est pas agréable ça fait
perdre l'avancé fait descendre la valeur
boursière
mais c'est surtout un enjeu de comme
c'est un surtout l'image de marque là
qui est affecté par ce registre est
est-ce que c'est mieux pour l'image
d'une entreprise en ce moment de se
retirer de facebook ou d'un continuer a
annoncé sur facebook c'est l'autre et
les mains parce que ils n'ont pas
annoncé quitter facebook pour annoncer à
leurs centaines de milles
d'abonnés ou à leurs statistiques
d'audience et c'est là c'est seulement
un mois pendant le mois de juillet donc
son annonce par exemple ce qu'on achète
vraiment des produits financiers pendant
le mois de juillet bref son âge est pas
un autre produit pendant ses vacances
dans les vallons mois de vacances c'est
peut-être pas si dommageable de cesser
de faire de la publicité sur facebook
alors que si vous êtes nommé dans tout
les médias comme en ce moment
tradi plus traditionnels par exemple à
dans une dans un mouvement qu un peu
dans la constellation du black line
rider mais c'est sûr que c'est un
classement marketing ou d'image de
marque pour ces entreprises qui est très
rentable à mon avis il peut se regarder
s'il ya pas plus de wii qu'est-ce qui
pourrait vraiment faire mal à facebook
dans la mesure où des entrepôts où il ya
un mouvement qui à la base est animé par
une quelque chose de réel c'est-à-dire
de dénoncer une façon de faire de
facebook alors comment atteindre
véritablement un objectif de faire
reculer ou de faire changer facebook
déjà il faudrait savoir ce qu'on demande
précisément à facebook a parce que les
demandes qui sont faites à facebook
facebook a déjà l'air d'y répondre avant
même que les demandes soient faits à
l'arrière des jo ce qui est un peu un
flou mais si par exemple on voudrait
avoir un levier qui fonctionne avec la
plateforme
ben c'est celle ci ne s'est massivement
qu'il faudrait que les gens quittent la
plateforme
sauf qu'en ce moment quitter la
plateforme cse s'est tellement se priver
de beaucoup de possibilités de
communication c'est sortir du monde en
quelque part on est majoritairement sur
facebook juste au québec on est plus de
70% de la population avec un compte là
dessus et puis on est jeune plus on est
actif sur la plateforme
donc c'est peut-être couper les liens
avec la famille les collègues et c'est
donc tout se fait en sorte que c'est
c'est surtout pas les annonceurs qui
vont faire pression de toute façon faut
se poser la question est ce que vraiment
les gens vont là où il y à des
annonceurs ou les annonceurs vont t'ils
là où sont les gens simples c'est une
bonne solution car bien que l'on
comprend bien c'est un mouvement qui est
temporaire pendant quelques semaines on
peut boycotter un peu mais pas trop
finalement mais faut voir est ce que les
entreprises parce que je pense pas que
les entreprises sont mal intentionnées
pense peut-être même que plusieurs ne
font pas être partant d'ordre c'est
juste que c'est pas un gros risque à
prendre pour le faire actuellement
oui j'en ai vu aucune mois annoncé
quitter justement par exemple fermer
complètement leurs pages personne
annoncer ça alors c'est facile en ce
moment comme engagement c'est assez
léger faut voir si elle se met vraiment
à le faire et à générer un mouvement
populaire comme par exemple black
l'animateur est capable de le faire ce
que ça va fonctionner il va falloir
qu'il ya une alternative que des
équivalences au niveau des fonctions
qu'on aime utiliser et en ce moment il
n'y a pas beaucoup de compétitions à
facebook c'est seul problème alors je
moi je vois mal comment on pourrait
faire véritablement mal à cette
admirable et de toute façon elle est
déjà entrée de mettre sur pied ce qu'on
lui demande de mettre sur pied alors
c'est terrible pour un maillon
fondamental qui dérange tant chez mark
zuckerberg le pdg fondateur mais en fait
c'est qu'il ya deux grandes positions
qui sont souvent très mal compris people
je vais essayer de vulgariser là c'est
que d'un côté vous avez toutes les
décisions qui touchent la liberté
d'expression la circulation et l'accès à
l'information la démocratie la
protection des systèmes et des processus
électoral tout ça qui doit prendre ces
décisions là ok d'un côté il ya ceux qui
disent bac c'est l'entreprise à peu
prendre la décision qu'elle soit
étrangère conte et canadiens sont des
entreprises américaines une entreprise
privée américain doit prendre ces
décisions là parce que c'est elle qui
est propriétaire de son produit par
exemple tandis qu'un autre posture qui
est celle de zuckerberg c'est de dire
non nous ne sommes pas imputable nous ne
sommes pas légitime
nous ne pouvons pas prendre cette
décision là alors nous demandons aux
états d'encadrer et de prendre le de
prendre la patate chaude dans le fond de
cette décision-là est bon le ca s'est
pas fait alors il commence à instaurer
des mécanismes pour ne pas justement se
retrouver avec cette fois cet arbitraire
là en quelques heures ils ont ils ont
annoncé déjà un tribunal par exemple
international qui est pas encore tout à
fait formé ailleurs 40 mmm éminemment
qui vont pouvoir trancher les grandes
décisions
ils ont décidé de laisser les publicités
les publicités politiques leur ont géré
pas ce qui est vrai ou faux là dedans on
up to me achat sur en ligne dans une
librairie pour que les journalistes
puissent les voir est ce que tous les
citoyens
donc on essaie de trouver des mécanismes
pour un peu protéger la démocratie de la
position
dam en terre c'est quoi quand tu es
jolie démocratie plus d'imputabilité et
de la part d auxerre on agit tout de
suite
sauf que pour les perceptions populaire
c'est qu'on a l'impression que facebook
n'agit pas en réalité voile alors que
c'est juste une façon différente d'âge
et en fer fait vous avez bien vulgarisé
j'ai bien compris il suis sûr qu'à la
maison également on a bien compris nelly
brière merci beaucoup
bonne soirée